the majority of poor people in the world
are women and girls in developing
countries where the the single largest
occupation for women is agriculture in
increasingly in Africa and in Asia in
particular women are doing the bulk of
the farming yet women are almost always
locked out of ownership over the most
important asset land so it's it's
extremely important that we pay
attention to who within the household
holds legal rights the ugly truth is is
that it is mostly men who are holding
women back men dominate the policy arena
men dominate the decision-making at the
community level at the household level
and we have to address the misconception
that empowering women means you're
disempowering men that's a myth it's a
misconception empowering one empowers
all empowering women empowers men
children families and ultimately the
entire society women's economic
empowerment is it's not a women's issue
it's a societal issue if we're going to
address some of the largest challenges
we have poverty food security we are
going to have to empower women they have
been underutilized as social and
economic change agents they are the ones
doing much if not the bulk of of the
farming so their relationship to land
and other productive resources is
critically important so the way that we
have gone about trying to fight against
I would say the the opposition is to get
men to understand two things one it
doesn't disempower men and two it's a
societal issue and then if you want to
address the societal issue you you just
have to empower women in the society one
of the lessons learned for us
is that when appealing to men about the
importance of empowering women is that
we often find more success appealing to
them in the interest of their daughters
rather than their wives most fathers do
want the best for their daughters when
you appeal to them in the interests of
their daughters they find it I think
somehow less threatening then appealing
to them in their interest of their of
their lives even in the most patriarchal
societies men understand that women are
entrusted to do some of the most
important work that is caring for
children raising children so you can
often appeal to them from where they are
coming from I mean trying to shove some
Western notions of equality down the
throats of people who who who see it as
threatening is isn't isn't always the
most effective way but if you appeal to
them in terms of what is the best for
your community what is the best for your
broader society what is the best for
your families you often can address that
resistance
you